elliot page formerly known as ellen has
publicly come out as transgender
the juno star announced the news tuesday
on instagram writing
hi friends i want to share with you that
i am trans
my pronouns are he and they and my name
is elliot i feel lucky to be writing
this
to be here to have arrived at this place
in my life
i feel overwhelming gratitude for the
incredible people who have supported me
along this journey it was a similar
sentiment
elliott previously shared with et when
they came out as
gay in 2015. i feel so
happy and i feel so different from how i
felt when i was closeted
and to have experiences where i meet
people
who have been touched in some way um
by you know me just getting to be who i
am is
such an incredible experience to get to
share with someone i feel grateful for
it
and you know i'm in a very fortunate
place in my life
the oscar-nominated actor adds in his
letter how remarkable it is to pursue
his authentic self
sharing the more i hold myself close and
fully embrace who i
am the more i dream the more my heart
grows
and the more i thrive elliot also
revealed that even though he's feeling
profoundly happy right now
he still has some fears writing quote
i'm scared of the invasiveness the hate
the jokes
and the violence the umbrella academy
star
then noted that this year alone at least
40 transgender people have been murdered
and called out political leaders who
have been attacking the transgender
community
writing enough is enough elliot
concluded his post
with a heartfelt message to all the
trans people who deal with harassment
self-loathing abuse and the threat of
violence
every day i see you i love you and i
will do
everything i can to change this world
for the better
i'm a very privileged person i'm a very
privileged gay person
and to get to talk about issues
particularly those
that affect people much much more
vulnerable than me
i feel really grateful to be in a
position where potentially
potentially i can i can do little things
or whatever i possibly can
to help in what any way i can eliot's
wife professional dancer and
choreographer emma portner
reposted the letter and showed her
support in the caption
i am so proud of elliot page elliott's
existence is a gift in and of itself
shine on sweet e love you so much
it's just the most amazing thing miley
cyrus commented
elliott rules and pop rock duo tegan and
sarah tweeted
your strength bravery and activism not
to mention all the art you contribute to
this earth
is truly special